après la guerre rares étaient les
petites antilles à disposer d'une piste
d'atterrissage est d'ailleurs l'idée
même de créer des pistes sur certaines
de ces zyl relevait du rêve un peu fou
[Musique]
heureusement quelques aviateurs
audacieux qui y ont cru
certains sont devenus des personnages
emblématiques pour tous les pilotes de
la région exemple josé dormoy
et bien lui dedans moi j'ai une énorme
admiration pour lui il est parti à l'âge
16 ou 17 ans de sa vie familiale en
guadeloupe et il a été rejoint dans les
franches française de google
et puis il est devenu pilote de chasse
josé dormoy a laissé son empreinte aux
antilles sous le surnom de mister hype
car il avait toujours la pipe à la
bouche même aux commandes de son avion
dormoy a bien connu un autre personnage
de légende marin aventurier et
visionnaire
rémy de nn le premier à avoir eu l'idée
de poser un avion à saint barthélemy il
a été apporté aux décors il a appris à
piloter et la chaîne cet avion et puis
le seul endroit possible à son bord et
au sol à pessac allemand du terrain est
venu chez peser et si bientôt avec des
bimoteurs que de nn s'opposera
régulièrement entre la colline et la mer
yport de l'extrémité du terrain de saint
jean
[Musique]
très peu de personnes croyaient mais il
y accueille comme dans beaucoup de
choses et il est arrivé alors ils ont
dit non seulement rémy de nn ne s'est
pas tué mais il ne lui fallut pas
beaucoup de temps pour convaincre les
habitants et les visiteurs de l'intérêt
de l'aviation comme hypothèse s'est très
bien passé que l'on rende hommage aux
propriétaires c'est l'idée qui en fit à
coopérer en faisant couper les arbres en
bouchant la nar l'artiste n'a été
reconnue par l'administration que 10 à
12 ans après il y avait déjà les fils
électriques et le fils de téléphonie qui
passait là lui se poser quand même
s'arrangeant passer en dessous
ces terrains est elle un pâturage ou
mais mon père a baissé ses bêtes à
cornes et ses moutons dans la maison
familiale toujours situé en bord de
piste hippolyte les d un des premiers
pilotes de lille se souvient on se
présentait à assez bas de façon que le
gardien fait se voir et savait
automatiquement que c'était pour
atterrir il y avait quelqu'un qui
soignait les moutons pour monsieur
l'aider et qui au passage de l'avion
avait une boîte avec des cailloux là
dedans et il sonne elle et les cailloux
dans la boîte pour faire évacuer les
moutons pour que les jeunes puissent se
poser
petit à petit l'aérodrome de saint
barthélémy s'est développée et même les
capitaines de goélettes ont commencé à
voyager en avion à partir du moment où
l'avion est arrivé tout a changé
oui l aérodrome de saint jean est
rapidement devenu un des lieux les plus
fréquentés de lille
le nombre de personnes souhaitant se
déplacer en avion plutôt qu'en bateau ne
cessait de croître
il fallait répondre à la demande
imaginez un système il fallait créer une
compagnie aérienne
tin tam art and îlot désert au large de
saint-martin pas de relief
l'endroit idéal pour un aventurier comme
de nn pour créer une base aérienne 7000
plate donc avait pas beaucoup de travaux
à faire pour faire une piste
d'atterrissage
j'ai choisi ta main parce que c'est mort
c'est un territoire français que la
seule piste vraiment organisé de
l'époque dans la région et l aérodrome
de juliana contre les hollandais pendant
la guerre et lille et en place
d'ailleurs les populations anglais de la
région la pêche la thaïlande
j'étais simplement avec un bateau avec
l'équipage journée on arrache et les
quelques plantes qui était propre bouche
et une partie des trucs crainte qu'elle
avait beaucoup ch était il s'est posé on
s'est établie là et c'est comme ça qu'il
a décidé de créer six compagnies qui
avaient léger comme symbole chammartin
guadeloupe est pas de hors jeu mais
n'est pas la c1 compagnies aériennes
antillaise il avait une piste qui
faisait quelques centaines de mètres
chaque fois qu'on se posait condé couler
c'était un exploit on n'était pas sûr
d'y arriver
en 1946 trouver des avions n'étaient pas
très compliqué si on n'était pas trop
regardants sur leurs états et les
acheter à porto rico il les faisait
venir des états unis les avions coûtait
pas cher
ils étaient détruits parce qu'il
pourrisse est dans les hangars donc
c'était c'était un investissement minime
avec énormément de pièces détachées on
avait environ cinq ou six avions c'était
les surplus de guerre américaine en
mêlée qu'elle y avait deux ils arrivent
les avions qui utilisait à l'époque
c'étaient des quatre places n'est cinq
places et c'est vraiment des petits
avions il ya jamais eu de gros avions un
donc c'était et transporter des gens
comme ça c'était un coût de 2,3
personnes quatre personnes c'est tout
coin à les passagers je pense qu'il
devrait avoir peur à ces s'ouvrant
puisque au tout début c'était dans des
vieux à viande et c'est à dire vulgaire
et tout ça alors c'était pas de 3 po va
que voulez vous quand même
[Musique]